lizzo teamed up with jimmy kimmel live  to the surprise of some unsuspecting  fans during edition of undercover sing  where fans were brought into a room  thinking they were going to give  their reaction to some of lizzo's  hottest song  but the singer was actually watching all  of this go down from the next room and  surprise fans one by one with a literal  pinch me moment for a fan named johnny  take a look we'll see you next time  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  hey  oh i thought this was the bathroom  [Laughter]  pinch me  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Applause]  hey  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  turn around  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  did that piercing hurt on your face  [Music]  [Laughter]  virgo come on  oh it's nice to meet you